so elon musk and his boring company are
doing god's work uh
their invention the innovative loop is
going to define cities and city planning
for decades perhaps centuries to come
i mean moving people fast in tunnels
from point a to point b
it's an unheard of concept and no one
has thought about this before obviously
but unfortunately elon musk seems to
have run into
some difficulties with the loop loops
construction
which resulted in two major scale downs
of the concept
at first it was imagined as a 200 miles
per hour
guide wheel system where cars go on
sleds
also these pods which have their own
wheels
and then this was scaled down i guess to
the guidance system to this guide wheel
solution which unfortunately for some
reason also didn't work out
honestly i have no idea why uh perhaps
this
uh guide wheel system is presently too
advanced
for human civilization to accomplish and
so we are at the
paved tunnel concept presented to us in
a flashy boring company video
and here i have to stop and say elon
wait
i have figured something out here that's
right i'm gonna fix your loop buddy
i have a big brain just like you so
let's unify our brain capacities to work
something out here okay
all right so i think you need to go back
to the guide wheel system because the
paving uh you know paving a tunnel and
then running regular cars in it
at high speeds brings with it the
problem of high tire wear
which will significantly drive up
maintenance costs and it will be
generally an inconvenience which we
don't want so instead let's stick with
the guideways i would say
i can see that the sleds and the pods
have their own wheels and they're uh
kind of like guided on one rail but i
have a better
idea how about we have a double
innovative reinforced steel and concrete
uh high-tech guideway to guide the pods
and instead of having rubber wheels on
them we can put
steel wheels on them so they can
actually glide on these high-tech
dual steel guideways steel is much more
durable and will be able to achieve much
smoother rides
at much lower maintenance costs and so
now let's talk about the
layout of the whole system elon you have
proposed a lot of small elevators all
over the city
but i would say within the cities there
are distinct
areas where people a lot of people want
to go so i say let's try and concentrate
the exits in these areas now the car
elevators are a very nice idea however
those are multiple multiple points of
failure on your system meaning
more chance for mistakes breakdowns etc
so what if we didn't actually bring the
vehicle to the surface
but we take the people down on these ai
controlled
automated self-moving hyper stairs
i call them alright so now people are
being whisked down to
high-tech passenger pods in these
cluster stations
on the hyper stairs so this is already
very good and very high tech
however there's one last thing that i
don't like is that every single pod has
its own
engine and all the machinery associated
with it so why don't we
connect the pods into one hyper pod
that has one or two big big engines
which is
a much better economy of scale also i
would advise building the first loop
systems in
very congested sort of very high demand
areas this would be the easiest solution
to take an area
where a lot of people want to go from
one definite area
to another definite area meaning that
our long hyper pods could
go back and forth the whole day or just
in one pair of tunnels
instead of having like 10 12 30. and on
this congested high demand fixed route
they could thus transport a [ __ ] ton of
people and for added comfort and for
more
futuristic interior design we could have
the
pods making up the hyper pod connecting
to each other physically so that you can
walk from one end into the other like a
big
pipe and since this is a fixed route
instead of batteries
we could have a third rail where the
whole machinery could
draw power from i came up with this all
by myself inspired by elon's genius
i call it the epic 420 thanos keanu
reeves ultra line
now you might be asking hang on a second
where are the private cars in this
system i mean we have the pods but where
do our teslas and other electric cars
fit in
and i am very glad you asked in major
cities in very congested areas
space is at a premium we simply cannot
afford to
bring everyone's cars in so why not
leave the car
on the outskirts in a big convenient
mega parking lot
right next to the station from the
parking lot you could be transported
down to the station in immense comfort
on the aforementioned ai controlled auto
stairs
and if your destination is not near a
loop station the aforementioned stairs
could take you up to the surface where
you could transition in extreme comfort
to a surface pod
these surface spots have rubber wheels
four of them or even more perhaps
and are designed to transport you to
destinations which are a bit more
farther away from tunnels
hell we could even put these dual
reinforced steel hyper guideways on the
streets maybe sink them even in the
asphalts that are passable
and hook multiple pods together and so
that they can travel on the streets in
dedicated lanes
that way we achieve a smooth and fast
ride and we don't even have to tunnel
and here's the best part once the system
grows dense enough
you don't even need a personal car
anymore and isn't that just awesome no
more sitting in traffic jams
no more driving around looking for
parking lots the system will just take
you from point a to point b
without having to drag two tons of metal
and plastic with you
which would be of course your personal
car so yeah
elon call me i'm open for investment
proposals
uh i'm ready to share in your wealth and
i am ready to receive sponsorship money
and interview requests from major news
organizations
the very knowledgeable tech magazines
that treated the loop and the hyperloop
as like actually viable ideas
so yeah i'm i'm a genius i guess
so call me holy [ __ ] [ __ ]